let's talk yeah - I feel like like the
time the whole point of the podcast is
the moments in life and everything
changed yes did you ever think to
yourself when you were just a little kid
you know what I'm gonna when I get older
I'm gonna be this internationally
renowned inspirational figure that's
gonna really put a dent in the universe
I just really believe in my thesis I
think well everybody here under 30 is
rushing to do stuff to close
insecurities and vulnerabilities and
it's making them do things that they're
gonna regret long-term and I just didn't
I just you know what it feels like to be
27 years old and see your college
friends and they're making jokes that
you work in your dad's liquor store like
I just was able to be in my own head and
not care about what anybody else thought
and that would be my biggest piece of
advice because I genuinely believe all
of you are in a rush for that I don't
think you care about a BMW or a Rolex or
like spending a lot of money on a
vacation for any other reason because of
the psychological aspects of how that
positions you to other people I really
believe that and so I just think people
you know like the young man out if he's
here who's like I'm killing it I want to
start teaching other people he's he's so
young like anybody could do well at Wall
Street the last six years everybody I
definitely thought I was different at an
extremely young age I grew up in a world
that didn't reward outwardly the things
that I was about it still blows my mind
that I was you know 15 16 years old
making real money in my side businesses
and every teacher I had and every
friends parent thought I was gonna be a
loser man I know where we're putting
we're locking in a show with him or like
a session right a meeting Jonathan man
keep [ __ ] grinding man all that
attention on you
the food is just your passion I mean
this is killing my killing my vibe let
them just I'd rather you actually hit
the car at this point just [ __ ] hit
it anyway guys who's reading crushing it
the audio is good on halfway done what
am i finishing it next week alright
there's something broken now yeah blank
that [ __ ] this plate
I want all-new gonna I'm only gonna IV
this is absurd I don't believe you look
for something else
look at that where your button what's
that R your button that's lit up that's
real that's down below
[Laughter]
turn up the cars go get out the car wipe
this I'm [ __ ] gonna wipe the snow let
me out of here
oh [ __ ] where it's green I do have to do
it for it gotta entertain these people
trying to entertain these people AJ I
got to bounce tomorrow morning because I
can't watch the [ __ ] Patriots playing
a game but they're not it's been good
about you how are things
oh good it is [ __ ] cold sit sit sit
you wanna bring some chairs over yeah
I'm sorry my treat like the next
generation right and like a straight
straight live stream in 2k on Twitch no
because there cuz there and there's so
much money then leave it untight
like yeah man it's gonna be real
interesting to watch it's coming like I
don't think people like I'm talking
about like I mean if governments can be
folded by this leaks can be folded by
this like this is way bigger like it may
not even hit his generation might be you
got anybody younger than you if they had
like a nine-year-old brother
it's that kid legitly could be live in a
world where I just think the Internet
kills everything in the middle and so
what happened to bookstores had happened
to you know limo services right that's
nobody gives a [ __ ] about Steph Curry
they care about his attention let him
[ __ ] if you can shoot from 40 feet out
or score 60 a night they care that kids
are influenced by what you say
and whether you're [ __ ] Meek Mill or
[ __ ] LeBron or [ __ ] CNN it's all
the same [ __ ]
it just it's it's it's understanding the
strength of like if you look if you love
if you love twitch you go all-in on
twitch if you love fashion you go all-in
on fashion because every athlete wants
to be a rapper every rapper wants to be
an athlete and they all want to be
entrepreneurs that's real right you know
why you know why you know why they want
to be me cuz they can you need to be
born blast out your ass to be him or
Robin me junior football player he's a
[ __ ] house he's all of us in one man
with no body fat did you see him take
off my shirt you see that [ __ ] so that's
why cuz it's actually true I want to be
like Mike [ __ ] that this sneaker you can
actually be that I'll give you it right
now go on Craigslist take all the free
[ __ ] that they're offering in on the
free page in the classifieds bring it
home take a picture put it on Facebook
marketplace and make $400 a week yo just
sell [ __ ] like it about a month he's not
going to think that shirt is as good as
he think we do that you know that works
so instead of like let be your house
while you're at Duke take a picture sell
[ __ ] the 50 craigslist thing is crazy
literally anybody on welfare I think
could become wealthy just by having a
phone and just you could have a studio
you go to the person's house
everybody's got a [ __ ] [ __ ] Kerry
Kerry this [ __ ] on the bus if you're
broke grab this and go on the bus sit on
the bus like this everybody look at you
be like yeah yeah keep laughing come
home do it take a picture and post it on
Facebook marketplace 15 bucks
something's like y'all take your table
ding dong yo hello here you go
sold you just made what are you doing
with and then somebody's going to say
but damned it's gonna take 40 minutes to
go there 40 minutes to take on the bus
five minutes to post seven minutes I'm
like but what are you doing through time
anyway everybody can win it's about
being yourself the truth is the
fucking's formula that's the strategy
you know what I mean
on in [ __ ] Hoboken I'm telling you
right now that's literally $35 on
Facebook marketplace if you just pick it
up it's seven minutes of your time it's
15 minutes your time turn off the music
ah B turn off the music Valley honestly
I think I just eliminated for the first
time I think I just eliminated for the
first time in my career the excuse of no
money I think it just happened this is
like a big day for me literally for 30
years I've had a like pander to that
excuse it's over it's actually over
it's called Craigslist free section by
side let us say buy it go take it for
free cuz most people just want you to
pick it up there's a bigger what have
you if you happen to actually have like
a truck or like a bigger vehicle then
you are really set my friends Craigslist
free to then realist it on Facebook
marketplace the arbitrage of the
Internet we see this in retail where
people buy things in China post on
Amazon for things of that nature by on
Marshalls comm sell on Amazon like it
happens the much more humble version
when you got nothing if you're just
sitting like I need money like all those
people that were like yo can somebody
buy me Gary B's book I can't afford it
that means you know $17 it's there man I
think you could make and I really think
a real hustler
I think I think it's like $300 a week
nah I don't that I feel like people I
think 300 bucks a week if you're not
even doing it full-time I think if you
take your 6:00 p.m. to 9:00 p.m. Monday
and Tuesday picking up [ __ ] and then be
posting it on Facebook marketplace and
then meeting people on Saturday to come
to your home and grab it I think it's a
book sweet man
I think it can be even bigger what are
you why are we so lost isn't it
when's he going how
it's a lot of attractive there's a lot
of attractive people in here attractive
people
[Music]
just cameras everywhere
[ __ ] cameras everywhere alright let's
go I go what's going on they know about
it and they're against the ort --m the
PR team whose PR hmm should we meet in a
parking lot
can you cower my Twitter and see what
people can you look at all my the yeah
we can you do that too actually can you
look at all the tweets replies who looks
like we're trying to do a meet up
because I have to be at Mall of America
so I figured I'd be like hey I could
meet you there real quick I didn't want
to disrupt it in any way but it seems
like security is not excited about or
something I don't know the details yet I
figured with all the football players
there big crowds but you know so we're
on our way there
it's snowing trying to figure it out
gotta um move it to the IHOP what do you
think
I bet you they know who I am I've like
interacted with the Walt Mall of America
Twitter account Lee they're gonna hello
sir you're out of here
yeah [ __ ] that we're gonna lose snapchat
I'm moving the Meetup I'm gonna move it
to the the I hop on Killebrew I'm just
not gonna be able to pull this off at
the Mall of America I just feel like
they're gonna kick me out so I buy a
thousand dollars with a pancake so they
let us all in they think I'm in that bus
go straight go straight go straight go
straight
I want to go away from Pope pull in
right here yep watch this
you get our first bathroom I'm gonna be
like hey
yo don't slip don't slip
yeah you guys know good to see you go
man there's a lot of people listening
who don't know I am and so it's tough to
come out the gate after your said such a
nice thing to say yes I knew but I look
for example actually let's do this let's
do this backwards I really think it's an
extremely small fraction of the actual
way it all plays out right this minute
okay so I think we sit here 27 years
from now and it starts getting really
weird really like really weird in terms
of I think everybody will know who I am
right and I think I'm gonna have a real
positive impact just someone selling a
TV for 20 bucks immediately posted it on
like 50 people sold it for 200 bucks
flip let's go could you take a picture
of this let's do it awesome I should not
forget this just one do something about
to tell you Jeff I know you could often
hearing that and I thank you one less
thing it's kind of [ __ ] up can you
sign my share I have yes I have no I
have no crushing a for you to sign
no arrays brother yeah I got you okay
the update is [ __ ] cold and we're
going inside I'm gonna keep the line the
way it was it pulled from opposite
directions most of my success comes from
that and you know and maybe that double
life I lived during my childhood cuz I'm
not scared of losing because I was
telling told that I was losing right you
were gonna lose anyway that's right
right they they were saying look you're
not gonna bounce to anything anyway so
in your mind you're thinking house money
house money and I didn't believe that
you know wasn't even just like well if I
have nothing to lose I was like you're
wrong what is making you not jump all in
usually not crazy results in a short
period of time which means you're
looking for you
you know you're not looking for
marriages you're looking for hookups
that's why you haven't figured it out
everybody thinks that everybody is
unstuck it's you know what this is a
great two themes in a row everybody
stuck on the idea of it guys it's not
the idea of it ways wasn't a new
innovation right Instagram wasn't a new
innovation Spotify wasn't a new in it
like guys it's like you know it's like
it's execution so usually people are
bouncing around their businesses because
they think I could come up with idea
it's gonna launch and [ __ ] Nirvana is
gonna come you know it's just not it's
[ __ ] execution nothing I've ever done
in my life is some new thing I've just
done it better
harder longer like it's just in the
edges Elon Musk is not in this room
right now you understand so you're
bouncing around because you're not
getting the traction that you're looking
for because you're probably judging way
too fast
vaynermedia sucks [ __ ] the first two
years me and AJ had a long debate about
selling it for a million dollars to
buddy media twenty nine months in yeah I
mean like everybody's like things like
guys most people are not actual
entrepreneurs and you we are as a
collective universe right now being
tricked that we are just keep that in
mind
[Music]